I need to know how the conversation goes
when you get a call to say do you want
to play Pikachu where does that yes come
yeah I'd like I hope yeah I don't know I
it was a strange thing what they did was
they did did this the right way because
like first off you know Pokemon in
general is legit like catnip to children
so they sent me this fully rendered
detective Pikachu
and they'd married it and paired it with
my voice from these dialogue from
Deadpool won and so there I was watching
looking at this like completely hyper
realistic photo realistic detected
Pikachu on my computer and my daughter
kind of cruises by and it's just like
glued to it what makes makes us watch it
a hundred times in a row so I was kind
of in yeah even if the script was just
like literally made of old spit I've
been like yep I'm doing it I'm in I need
more of that validation for my child so
did she knew immediately and she so was
it I'm trying to figure out how that
goes like I see this stuffed animal but
it's my dad how does that work she's
never really put it together I don't
think she really understands that I'm
Pikachu and I think she's just sort of
because she didn't say that it sounds
like she's because she saw the trailer I
was like that sounds like you daddy I
was like it doesn't but there was no set
they always come with the Blake and I
travel with each move we all as a family
go but there was no set for detective
Pikachu because I was in motion capture
the whole time so it was all done in
like hotel rooms or random you know
stages in New York and different places
so she's not put it together that I'm
detective Pikachu but she has put it
together that she is going to see this
movie on opening day so we're gonna take
her and so it was a plus to UM your
daughter that you sounded that Pikachu
sounded like you but Blake said you
didn't even change your voice no no no I
Michelle I tried the first day the first
day I was like okay like wait would you
like a hard-boiled sort of like Bronx
kind
you know I detected kind of film noir
thing and they're like just do Ryan
Reynolds okay that's that's what we're
paying you for it so I can do right I
know so yeah I did it and in the end it
was right because it kind of like I love
the idea that you have this a super
adorable little yellow guy whose voice
is this like an impatient grumpy acerbic
gent and you know I like a patient from
being a survey closer this was like my
three favorite colors well I will say I
walked in thinking this is not a movie
for me I walked out like oh right Nicole
seriously
I literally I'm not trying to blow your
head up but I'll do it anyway I I love
my job I'm very lucky to get to do what
I do and you know I'm very lucky to be a
part of a movie that isn't just like it
just wife wants the seat and my kids
want to see and I don't take that for
granted for a second cuz they will never
see Deadpool I was gonna say have your
baby's been able to see anything else
they've been on set a ton yeah come on
stat a ton but even then I can't do it
cuz I where the scar makeup I'm all
covered in scars so as soon as they come
once didn't see that they just bought
like I just I know they're gonna be
re-enacting this with crude sock puppets
with a therapist in 20 minutes I'll just
keep them away from set when I'm in the
scar makeup but that is good because I
was going back and I'm trying to think
in my head like you played a dad played
a dad before done it a few times I did
definitely definitely maybe that's right
with Abigail Breslin right up yeah yeah
that was ten
I've played a dad a few times watch
first hold on a second I gotta unpack
that you don't want you know I've seen
somebody said someone haven't seen very
excellent I was gonna say it I've seen a
chunk how do you not sit through
Deadpool 50,000 times like the rest why
sit in the Edit room under I've seen
Deadpool one into 100 billion times how
do you how would Ryan Reynolds survive
in the world pool oh man I don't think I
would I don't know I wouldn't I can
barely live in a world full of people so
oh yeah that is like it is I I never
realized how culturally relevant it was
I'm pre I think I'm a pretty good
student of pop culture I had no idea the
problem was
I always known about it but it can
realize I was like this worldwide
phenomenon I love world building I love
this idea that these like all these
different creatures coexist sort of some
some level of harmony and stuff it's
like really whole messages in it I don't
know it's fun and funny and I just make
my life and tell me that Blake Lively
has like pokemon cards she does when you
have two kids your hands are pretty full
of other stuff you know
[Music]